President Biden seems to be getting his
hands dirty and signaling to his
Department of Justice that they better
think twice before going after his son
Hunter
sir there is something personal that's
affecting you your son while there's no
ties to you could be charged by your
Department of Justice how will that
impact your presidency
first of all my son's done nothing wrong
I trust him I have faith in him and it
impacts my presidency by making me feel
proud of you
Biden's warning shot comes as the White
House preps for the Fallout of a
potential Hunter Biden indictment
Politico reporting this people close to
the president still worry about the
personal toll it'll take how long can
you compartmentalize personal anger with
the attacks on honor and the political
calculation that he's better off not
responding to it
the U.S attorney investigating Hunter is
reportedly close to deciding on whether
to bring charges
but top house Republican James Comer is
asking the prosecutor to hold off
my message to the Department of Justice
is very loud and clear do not indict
Hunter Biden before Wednesday when you
have the opportunity to see the evidence
that the house oversight committee will
produce this is not just about the
president's son this is about the entire
Biden family what they're looking at
charging Hunter Biden on is a is a slap
on the wrist it's a drop in the bucket
so Wednesday will be a very big day for
the American people in getting the facts
presented to them
Dana how did you think that question was
posed to the president I didn't like the
way the question was posed I also think
that so remember last week we were
talking about how Biden doesn't do any
interviews right and so the White House
was like quick Let's do an interview
with MSNBC Stephanie Rule and we'll bury
it on a Friday night but nobody will
notice it and the only thing it makes
news on is Hunter and part of the reason
is every time we have the hunter clip
you see the full question and the
American people get it I I don't like
saying the American people viewers that
saw it would understand the what she did
is led the witness
right I'm I'm pretty good at leading the
witness right so you'd like try to get
the she's basically signaling I know
that you have nothing to do with
anything that went wrong with your son
right but so I'm just going to set that
up and give you that out before you even
have to say it yourself and then just
tee you up with a nice right ball that
you can do it's like I know Greg doesn't
put lifts in his shoes but you do really
have a very strong stature
I don't even know what I'm doing here
anymore
but Joe's pretty sneaky too right he
says Hunter's done nothing wrong he's he
pulled that amazing trick of having you
think past the story to a conclusion
that it's just Hunter we're worried
about not the big man it's like let's
say I make a crude analogy that gets me
in trouble on the five and I'm at HR and
I go look Jesse's done nothing wrong
I can't stress that enough Harold in
rare fashion made a great point I had to
go far back like a year to find it but
you suggested that Hunter and Joe could
have gone head first into the fentanyl
Scourge because as a former addict he
knows the turf I think it was you no I
didn't say that I think it was me that
was it you okay Jesse it was amazing
assistant without do nothing right but
it could it could say it could have
saved Hunter if he had actually done
that because as a businessman he
probably could have made a Headway into
finding out who the play players are if
he doesn't take all the drugs now
however uh that could be RFK Jr also a
prodigal son you know who partied more
than a Led Zeppelin tour bus you know if
he turns his pass into a plus uh and
makes and fights the fentanyl War he
could get a lot of votes including mine
do you have any points to make on this
yeah Harold so first off
um I think there's nothing wrong with
the president saying he thinks his his
son has done nothing wrong there's a
presumption of innocence in our in our
system I've been on this show and others
saying that President Trump is innocent
in any of these matters until the
matters that are before the court until
unless proven otherwise as every
American has given that gift two I
thought Mr Comer if he's going to say or
some are going to say that the president
was out alive then he was out of line
Congress appropriates means meaning that
Congress sets the budget and then
appropriates the money for these federal
agencies so if he's telling this agency
not to do its job I think that's wrong I
take it the political it's not lost to
me the political advantage that Mr Comer
is trying to gain there but if they have
information they should give it to the
justice department that's what the
justice department does not not his
Committee in terms of bringing bringing
charges this story has exhausted me I am
I've been confounded as to why it has
taken almost five years if not right at
five years for a U.S attorney and it
seems like there may be a special
counsel in the Justice Department also
looking at Hunter if he's done something
wrong let's get on with it let's make
the charges and let him confront those
charges and it appears from what his
father said the president is that he's
going to is going to plead innocent to
these charges that the young man has
done nothing wrong but whatever the case
the country doesn't deserve to have to
go through all this if he's done
something wrong present the case and
let's move on uh judge you might have a
different opinion about that I gotta
tell you I just can't believe that look
the presumption of innocence applies to
a defendant in a criminal court in the
court of public opinion prosecutors who
have evidence who have seen the evidence
don't put their head in the sand and say
oh he's innocent and then bring him to
court because they think he's innocent
they bring him to court because they
think he's guilty but having said that
Joe Biden knows just like everyone else
that he lied on that pistol permit
application Joe Biden the man who wants
to make sure none of us have guns thinks
it's okay for his son who was a drug
addict to file a pistol permit
application get a gun then throw it out
in a garbage can near a school but let's
go beyond that this this Comer saying
you got to wait for Wednesday and you're
saying you know what the truth is that
you know if they have the evidence they
should go forward with it they have the
evidence that's why there have been two
whistleblowers one from October of 2022
and one from last month whistleblowers
who have documents and evidence because
they are not being allowed to come
forward and testify because whenever
your boss says my son is innocent he is
not guilty you think uh Merrick Garland
is going to say hey just you know forget
about what Joe said indict the guy this
is a long-standing investigation because
of all of the problems and all of the
hurdles that they're trying to get over
Joe Biden has lied to us about his son
over and over again he lied when he said
he knew nothing about his son's overseas
business dealings and he lied about his
son's laptop when he went on a
presidential debate to interfere with a
presidential election and say 51
intelligence agents say it's Russian
disinformation that white house or that
hopeful White House orchestrated that
letter so Joe Biden is as much complicit
as his son is especially since he's
sharing the money and let me say one
more thing and I'll I'll hit him on the
personal level and that is Hunter has a
child that he won't recognize and Joe
Biden won't recognize his granddaughter
that's the Legacy that both of them are
lying about and I'm finished I like how
you didn't keep it personal for that
first two minutes that was really good
only for the end I wonder Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now